en 2005 le statisticien john ioannidis
publié un article académique au titre
inhabituellement plus ta clique wim
hoste published whissell findings of
fools en français pourquoi la plupart
des découvertes publiées recherche sont
fausses et bim
rien que ça l'article 2 ioannidis
justifie ensuite ce titre avec une
analyse bayésienne très convaincante en
fait
ioannidis ainsi que veritas y sommes
dans cette excellente vidéo et david
doit prendre ce super billet de blog
mais aussi finalement toute la
communauté statistiques et la communauté
scientifique ont fini par me convaincre
qu une publication scientifique était
généralement plus probablement une mes
informations qu une information fiable y
compris lorsqu'elles sont publiées dans
des journaux scientifiques comme tiger
woods et ce constat semble d'autant plus
valable que le résultat scientifique
publiée par est surprenant malléable et
liés à des intérêts économiques ou à des
motivations idéologiques en particulier
à chaque fois que vous lisez une
conclusion d'un article scientifique qui
vous fascine ou qui vous plaît
particulièrement
il semble qu'il soit alors préférable de
résister à votre envie instinctive
d'embrasser cette conclusion de lalique
et et de la partager
et bien sûr ce scepticisme envers les
articles scientifiques se doit d'être
des x il s'agit d'articles non
scientifique ou de tweets et bien bien
sûr surveiller d'encore plus près vos
propres intuitions dont les billets sont
souvent pire encore que ceux des
publications scientifiques ou en à
l'esstic en particulier dans le cas des
sciences il semble plus urgent que
j'aime de fortement distingué le
consensus scientifique de la dernière
publication scientifique en date ces
deux produits de la science ne semble
absolument pas mériter la même crédence
pour comprendre cette recommandation de
scepticisme envers de publications
scientifiques
je vous propose d'étudier un modèle très
simplifiée des publications
scientifiques
bien sûr ce modèle est beaucoup trop
simplifié pour être lui-même vraiment
descriptif des sciences mais bon tous
les modèles sont faux et surtout il me
semble que celui que l'on va étudier et
néanmoins utile pour estimer le
scepticisme allez quoi avoir envers une
publication scientifique dans notre
modèle simplifié des publications
scientifiques tout va commencer avec
l'énonciation d'une théorie qu'on va
chercher à rejeter dans le jargon de
cette théorie est appelée hypothèse nul
et on va supposer que cette hypothèse
nul peut être vraies ou fausses
l'objectif bien sûr c'est de rejeter les
hypothèses nul fausses et de ne pas
rejeter les hypothèses nul vrai pour
savoir si l'hypothèse nul peut être
rejetée
on va ensuite effectué une collecte de
données on va supposer qu'elle est au
standard ultime des sciences autrement
dit on va supposer qu'il s'agit d'un
test randomisées et contrôlées en double
aveugle
puis vient l'analyse des données on va
supposer que celle ci correspond à un
test statistique d'hypothèses nul avec
teva lui comme c'est le cas le plus
souvent en sciences à l'issue du test on
obtient une paix value et on va supposer
que son interprétation dépend d'un seuil
qu'on va fixer pour commencer à 5% comme
c'est le cas si souvent en sciences
si la paix value est inférieur au seuil
on dit que les données sont
statistiquement significative
et pour rappel statistiquement
significatif ne signifie absolument pas
cliniquement significatifs notamment à
cause de toutes sortes de problèmes dont
notamment les tailles des faits
statistiquement significatifs ça
signifie juste que conformément à la
méthode scientifique souvent préconisé
les données permettent alors de conclure
au rejet de l'hypothèse nul on va
maintenant considérer que seuls les
résultats statistiquement significatifs
sont publiés ça correspond pas mal à ce
qu'il se passe en science et par
ailleurs on peut noter que en général un
résultat non statistiquement
significatif n'est vraiment pas une
acceptation de l'hypothèse nul
cependant et contrairement aux modèles
joie de ioannidis on va supposer que
tous les résultats statistiquement
significatif ne sont pas publiés surtout
dans les grosses revues comme ledger et
silent hill d'oeuvre aura une sélection
ainsi dans notre modèle il existe deux
chemins vers la publication scientifique
soit on suit le bon chemin c'est à dire
qu'on est parti d'une hypothèse nul
fausses on l'a rejetée avec des données
statistiquement significatifs et on a
été publié soit on suit le mauvais
chemin
c'est à dire qu'on est parti d'une
hypothèse nude qui était en fait vrai
mais on a quand même obtenu des données
statistiquement significative qui ont
conduit à une publication
malheureusement sachant uniquement le
fait qu'un résultat est publié et sa
plus value il semble impossible de
déterminer lequel des deux chemins a été
suivi c'est même tout l'objet de cette
vidéo
sachant qu'un résultat est publié quel
crédit faut-il avoir en sa conclusion
qu'elle fut en particulier la cause de
sa publication
est-ce qu'elle réside dans la validité
de la publication ou est-ce uniquement
le fruit de bien et de fluctuations
statistiques le rejet de l'hypothèse
nulle part la paix value est elle la
conclusion qu'il aurait fallu avoir
[Musique]
pour répondre à ces questions on va
appliquer la formule deux pays''
et vu qu'on a que deux théories à
analyser à savoir hypothèse nul vrai et
hypothèses du fos on va pouvoir utiliser
le curseur de turing pour appliquer la
formule de baisse de manière plus simple
à comprendre
rappelons que la forme de baisse pour le
curseur de turing s'écrit position du
curseur a posteriori est égal à position
a priori plus le logarithme du rapport
de surprise de la donner si vous ne
savez pas de quoi je parle je vous
renvoie vers les deux derniers épisodes
on a détaillé cette équation
dans notre cas il y en fait de donner à
savoir le fait d'être statistiquement
significatifs et le fait d'être publié
on obtient ainsi l'équation fondamental
de la validité d'une publication
scientifique qui dit que le curseur a
posteriori est égal au cours sur a
priori plus le gars rythme du rapport de
surprise du résultat statistiquement
significatifs plus le logarithme du
rapport de surprise de la publication
sachant le résultat statistiquement
significative je vais me permettre de
renommée tous étaient rares en validité
est égal à préjuger plus stats - [ __ ] à
cliquer
autrement dit selon notre modèle
simplifié des publications scientifiques
la validité d'une publication se déduit
de l'addition de trois termes sa
crédibilité a priori les statistiques
d'étonner et le biais de publication de
la revue scientifique
[Musique]
on va maintenant essayer d'estimer ses
différents terme et on va commencer par
celui auquel on pense le plus souvent
les statistiques des données pour
calculer le déplacement du curseur due
aux statistiques des données
il nous faut nous demander à quel point
les données sont plus surprenante
sachant l'hypothèse d'une fausse quand
la sachant vrai et ça ça pose toutes
sortes de problèmes à commencer par
identifier quelles hypothèses adopter si
l'hypothèse nul est fausse quel est
l'hypothèse alternative à l'hypothèse
nul est bien pour simplifier on va
considérer l'hypothèse alternative qui
maximise la vraisemblance des données
autrement dit on va choisir l'hypothèse
alternative qui rend les données le
moins surprenant dans ce cas à supposer
une paix value de l'ordre de quelques
pourcents comme l'a fait remarquer le
statisticien ben johnson les données
sont alors quatre à quinze fois plus
surprenante dans le cas de l'hypothèse
nul que dans le cas de l'hypothèse
alternative de tels rapports de
surprises correspondent alors à un
déplacement de l'ordre de 2 à 4 bits en
direction de l'hypothèse alternative
alors ça c'est tout de même en supposant
que l'expérience a parfaitement été
réalisés cependant en pratique il semble
difficile d'écarter l'existence de biais
dans le protocole expérimental par
exemple le thermomètre a peut-être été
légèrement mal calibré ce qui l'a
conduit à systématiquement rajouter
quelques dixièmes de degrés dans la
température mesurée dès lors surtout si
ces effets sont mal compris par
l'analyse statistique
le rapport de surprise d'une paix value
à 1% pourrait être divisé par deux voire
par bien plus encore ce n'est finalement
peut être que de 1 à 3 bits seulement
qu'il convient de déplacer le curseur de
turing le temps que ça c'est uniquement
le résultat de l'analyse de données
cependant si on lit une étude publiée
c'est que cette étude a passé un second
filtre qui est le biais de publications
notre modèle simplifié ce biais de
publications et quand il fait par le
logarithme du rapport de surprise d'être
publié plus précisément
sachant le résultat statistiquement
significatifs la publication de l'étude
dans une grande revue demeurera de
l'ordre de la surprise car des revues
comme ça nageurs sont très sélectives ok
mais maintenant sachant que les
résultats sont statistiquement
significatifs à quel point est-ce plus
surprenant est republié s'il peut être
rejetée est vrai par position assise
elle est fausse intuitivement il semble
en fait bien plus probable qu'une revue
près
si j'ose met davantage en avant des
résultats novateur spectaculaire est
étonnant et du coup notamment vu d'être
davantage cité par la suite une revue
semble avoir l'initiative a publié des
conclusions contre intuitive des
conclusions qui interpelle des
conclusions qui appelle à davantage de
recherche et donc de citation or les
roja d'hypothèses qui ont l'air vrai
sont bien plus de ce genre c'est ainsi
qu'un statistiques significatives
semblable lorsque l' hypothèse rejetée
est vrai la publication de l'étude
semble en fait bien plus vraisemblable
que si l'hypothèse rejetée est bel et
bien fausse noter que cet effet sera
d'autant plus grand que le biais de
publications et potentiellement grand ce
qui sera d'autant plus le cas que les
revues auront l'embarras du choix
or cet embarras du choix a explosé suite
à l'augmentation du nombre de doctorants
mais aussi suite à l'augmentation du
prestige des revues déjà prestigieuse et
à celle de l'importance de publier dans
un climat publish or perish dès lors
surtout dans le contexte actuel de la
recherche
il semble raisonnable de rajouter un
déplacement du curseur disons d'un beat
vers le cas d'une hypothèse nul vrai en
combinant l'analyse statistique et le
biais de publications
il semble qu'une étude fondée
essentiellement sur une paix va lui
statistiquement significative fasse
bouger le curseur d'au plus 2 bits mais
peut-être même de bien moins encore que
cela dès lors la conclusion dépendra
énormément des préjugés
où était le curseur de turing
originalement est-ce que l'hypothèse nul
était originalement peu crédible
avait-on des raisons a priori de la
rejeter au profit de l'hypothèse
alternative et bien a priori j'ai envie
de dire non
de la même manière qu'un journal mêmes
scientifiques un biais de publications
les chercheurs semblent eux aussi avoir
clairement un biais dans le choix des
hypothèses nul à tester et oui on ne se
couvrent pas de gloire et de subventions
de recherche en rhd et montrant des
choses bien connu la carrière du
chercheur dépend de sa faculté à trouver
des résultats nouveau remarquable et
remarquée et pour cela il cherchera
souvent a déjoué les pronostics en
rejetant une hypothèse nul qui semblait
pourtant vrai et du coup a priori il
faut s'attendre à des tentatives de roja
d'hypothèses nul crédible or pour peu
que ces hypothèses nul est une cote de 1
contre 2 ou 1 contre 4
c'est à dire une crédence a priori de 20
à 33 %
il faut s'attendre à ce que malgré les
données statistiquement significatifs et
à cause en partie dues
la clique académique le curseur de
turing de l'hypothèse nul se déplace
légèrement vers l'hypothèse alternative
mais pas suffisamment pour conclure que
l'hypothèse alternative est davantage
crédible et bien sûr parfois le curseur
démarre avec un a priori beaucoup plus
marquée encore notamment dans certaines
disciplines dont l'objectif annoncé est
de mettre au défi des séances bien
établie dès lors à postériori résultats
publiés serait plus probablement faut
que vrai c'est en tout cas l'étonnante
conclusion de ioannidis les sciences
produisent probablement davantage aux
publications fausses oeuvres est alors
il faut bien préciser que cette
conclusion nous vient de notre modèle de
publication il simplifie à outrance le
processus de publication scientifique
ce qui est compliqué en pratique c'est
que d'un domaine à l'autre la méthode
des scientifiques c'est-à-dire la
méthode capic vraiment les scientifiques
varie beaucoup en particulier en
physique des particules le seuil de la
paix va lui est beaucoup plus faible si
bien que le terme statistiques de notre
équation fondamentale peut alors
correspondre à presque 20 buts de
déplacement du curseur de turing enfin
ça c'est si on ne prend pas en compte
les biens expérimentaux parce que dans
ce genre de cas le risque de biais
expérimental devient souvent prédominant
à l'instar dû cas des neutrinos plus
rapides que la lumière dont monsieur
fille parle dans cette vidéo
voilà qui devrait nous forcer à
remplacer le déplacement de 20 vite par
un déplacement de peut-être dix villes
seulement voire potentiellement moins
encore si votre confiance en
l'infaillibilité des experts et
mentalist dans des conditions extrêmes
et plus faible encore mais surtout la
physique théorique et plein de préjugés
très marquée et incroyablement justifier
les théories de la physique ont ainsi
souvent décote a priori plus grande que
20000 contreras encore la relativité
restreinte en particulier est en fait
une théorie ultra crédible de la
physique moderne
dès lors même en physique des particules
on pourrait devoir prendre au moins
certains résultats avec des pincettes
à l'instar de l'incroyable pète accord
cloud gate dont parle veritas y sommes
dans cette vidéo
bref même 1,5 si demain c'est à dire une
plus value de l'ordre de 10 puissance
moins 7
ça ne prouve pas la validité du rejet de
l'hypothèse nul
ok ça c'est la confusion à laquelle nous
amène notre petit motel jouer mais bien
sûr c'est un modèle ultra simplifié pour
rendre notre modèle simplifié davantage
descriptif des publications
scientifiques
on peut ajouter deux aspects importants
de la méthode des scientifiques
en premier lieu il ya l'effort de
cohérence théorique celle ci revient à
justifier que les préjugés bayésiens
contre l'hypothèse nuls sont en fait
probablement plus grand que nos préjugés
intuitif voilà qui forcerait un
déplacement du curseur de turing tout en
aboutissant à une publication
surprenante pour le commun des
scientifiques
un joli arguments théoriques ça compte
ça qu'on t'aime potentiellement beaucoup
plus qu'une expérience scientifique
cependant al'inverse il ya le problème
de la malléabilité de la méthode des
scientifiques qui combiné à des intérêts
financés ou à des motivations
idéologiques peut représenter un
incentive énorme à tout chercheur à
biaiser consciemment ou non ces
résultats par exemple en disant non mais
ça ne donnait je peux ne pas l'inclure
dans mon analyse parce que accroissement
un échantillon initial un peu bizarres
ou encore caen n'a pas réussi a rejeté
cette hypothèse une telle qu'on peut
tester une autre hypothèse nul que l'on
pourra peut être rejetée avec ces mêmes
données puis encore peu peut-être
essayer cette autre méthode statistique
peut-être qu'avec elle on va avoir des
résultats statistiquement significatifs
selon ioannidis ce fléau de la
malléabilité a conduit à des biens
énorme qu'il questionne la taille du
déplacement du curseur de turing suite à
l'analyse statistique
dès lors le curseur de turing pourrait
se retrouver à postériori quasiment là
où ils étaient a priori
or si on cherchait des résultats
surprenants cet a priori pourrait être
grandement en faveur de l'hypothèse nul
le rejet de cette hypothèse nul sera
alors très probablement une erreur
selon ioannidis et bien d'autres
notamment stijn cas dans de nombreux
domaines par exemple ceux liés à la
santé
ces vieilles aurait ainsi conduit à des
publications très majoritairement
erronée en croire ses auteurs
la plupart des conclusions scientifiques
récentes dans ces domaines ne semble
alors pas crédible
donc si je récapitule si l'on en croit
notre modèle simplifié des publications
scientifiques
ces publications semble beaucoup moins
fiable que ce qu'on pourrait croire à
priori en particulier il semble très
fallacieux de conclure quoi que ce soit
à partir d'une unique publications
scientifiques comme l'expliquent si bien
hygiène mentale
si on en croit le bannissement tout cas
une publication devrait surtout déplacer
le curseur de crédence et surtout pas le
positionner à un endroit donné
indépendamment de sa position a priori
bref je ne le dirai jamais assez mais
pensez juste ou du moins penser de
manière à y viennent c'est compliqué
dernière fois on avait appliqué le
curseur de turing à deux problèmes de
probabilité je suis très content de voir
qu'il n'a beaucoup parmi vous qui ont
écrit en commentaire qu'ils avaient
compris autres qu'à progresser dans leur
compréhension du mécanisme grandement
grâce à la vidéo précédente
donc si vous n'avez pas vu je vous la
recommande vivement pour mieux sentir
cette pensée bayésienne particulier dans
la vidéo précédente j'avais posé deux
défilés et je vous invite à y réfléchir
je vais donner la réponse
ça peut résister pas à mettre pause puis
aller voir les vidéos précédentes
et puis à réfléchir à ce problème donc
dans le premier défilé on demande à
monsieur logicien de penser à un de ces
garçons et de bercy c'est quel jour de
la semaine
l'aîné et réponse mardi et vous avez eu
plusieurs dents les commentaires avoir
fait remarquer que en fait cette réponse
est toujours aussi surprenante que le
monsieur logicien et deux garçons ou un
seul garçon puisque finalement la
réponse qui leur est donnée ont pu être
n'importe quel jour de la semaine de
façon avec avec la même probabilité et
du coup la vraisemblance de la donne est
égal à 1 7e que monsieur logicien et
deux garçons ou qu'il en ait qu'un seul
et du coup il n'y a pas de plus de
surprises dans un cas que de l'autre et
ça c'est implique que la posteriori sera
forcément égal à la priory or l'a priori
c'est le problème
monsieur lucien deux enfants dont au
moins l'un est un garçon et il est égal
du coup une priorité de un tiers pour
que l'eau soit un garçon aussi le défilé
de lui correspondait à jouer au hockey
avec monsieur logicien on supposait que
monsieur musiciens à au moins un as et
on lui demande s'il à l'as de piqué et
répond oui est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour nous et bien la réponse
est non parce que il est plus probable
qu'ils répondent oui à cette question
s'il a plusieurs à ce que s'il en a
qu'un seul
et du coup on n'est plus surpris par
cette réponse oui à la question il à
l'as de pique
si on suppose que monsieur le sien n'a
qu'un seul as
du coup le curseur de turing va
s'éloigner du cas où il n'a qu'un seul
as et se rapprocher du cas où il y en a
plusieurs
et du coup c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour nous puisqu'il est alors plus
probable que monsieur logicien à
plusieurs axes
elle espère que vous avez mais cette
vidéo et que vous fera réfléchir sur le
degré de validité de tout ce que l'on
dit en général parce que même si en
sciences c'est difficile eh bien
plus tard des autres domaines ce sera
encore plus difficile ce qu'il faut
c'est dire en particulier je rende
vivement cette vidéo est là haut de
yoann liste où il explique pourquoi est
ce qu'on ne trie sion selon lui nouveau
les études scientifiques ne permettre
qu'elles n'ont pas de bouger le curseur
de turing et qu'en gros il n'ya rien
soit vraiment fiable dans ces domaines à
cause d'énormes gains potentiels
on peut non seulement des problèmes de
facteurs de prison aggrave encore plus
là-bas légalité des conclusions
scientifiques
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser le
lac et le commentaire partagé quant aux
abonnés pour tromper sur des
visionnaires cet hiver pour leurs dons
et j'espère que mr et la prochaine fois
[Musique]